in the latest installment of what
happened in an election that occurred a
year and a half ago Michelle Obama was
asked how Trump won and she laid the
blame on Hillary
just kidding she blames sexism from
women against women in light of this
last election I'm concerned about us as
women and how we think if we're not
comfortable with the notion that a woman
could be our president compare it to
what may be so but our analysis seems a
symptom of a greater problem that
contributed to her party's loss it goes
back to seeing the group and not the
person I call it IPB identity politics
blindness they lost not because Hillary
was a woman they lost because all they
saw was a woman meanwhile Trump took
nothing for granted fact as many voters
would have happily voted for a woman
just not that one because unlike Trump
she didn't speak to their concerns she
only spoke of her entitlement she just
assumed that she had the vote and just
assuming a woman must vote for a woman
seems pretty insulting from a man humans
are more complex surprising and
interesting than liberals give them
credit for but more than anything
Trump's election is a lesson in effort
at least he's showed up he fought
Hillary didn't if Democrats learn from
that then they can win but if they
continue to dwell in this narrow-minded
intolerant universe where all people sit
in their own identity buckets where
their behavior is fixed forever by sex
or race they will lose and then what
group will they blame next what do you
think Kimberly do you think that
michelle phan would feel differently if
she were a left-wing woman it's not
really about gender no I don't think
it's really about gender I think you hit
the nail on the head when you said it's
about the candidate about people making
a choice based on the qualifications the
merit of the candidacy and what you saw
during this past election that people
related the working men and women across
the country felt that this was a
movement they wanted to be part of be
part of the the Trump campaign and
movement across the country to let that
blue-collar workers families middle
class not be left behind now if a
fantastic female candidate who in
out there in campaigned and hit all the
spots you were supposed to actually
spoke to the people in that way I hunted
percent believed they could prevail
mm-hmm perhaps Sunday Michelle Obama
will run for office I think she would do
quite well
Oprah Winfrey ran for office should
probably do quite well so it really is
just like a measure of what you have to
offer what's going on in the country at
the time how you speak to the issues and
Hillary has given a quite a few excuses
as to why she did not prevail in the
campaign and one of the latest that we
discussed on this show was she said that
she felt that people thought she was a
capitalist they didn't relate to her
well perhaps that's the case she did not
make the case to the everyday man and
woman effectively or persuasively enough
to get them to choose her hmm Dayna
thoughts as a woman not as a human being
but as a woman because always all we see
out of it debate about demographics
going on right now on Twitter but
basically saying that you know for a
long time
demographers have been saying look the
country is changing and the Democrats
are going to run away with this if the
Republicans don't figure this out and
that's been going up like 26 years and
it hasn't happened maybe it will happen
in the future but at the same time the
the sand is shifting beneath the
Democrats feet and there is a new
coalition that was built in 2016 and I
don't see what the Democrats are doing
to try to win back the blue-collar
workers we have a segment coming up in
the e block talking about economics
which is something really that is pretty
quite remarkable what the left is coming
up with when it comes to talking about
capitalism or not and but the other
thing is I would say the Republicans are
probably not doing enough yet
to figure out how to keep that coalition
in their corner yeah while we always get
into this little tiff I say humans are
more complex and interesting than
identity politics would supply and you
say but we do the same thing the
Republicans do the same thing oh I think
we're in an era of white identity
politics is represented by President
Trump that we've never seen like in this
country but anyway I want to come to
this point that I think that what
Michelle Obama said really appeals to
the basis of your argument great because
she said this was about credentials that
you know clearly we had the better
credentialed experience in terms of
preparing to be president candidate and
look what you guys elected you like
someone who has no experience whose
chaotic impulsive and all the rest so
and remember you got 52% of white woman
who voted for Trump and she's saying why
is that it previously
you know mrs. Obama has said you know
you can't wait for the next person to
save you you got to do it yourself and
women who were voting against women
because they're a woman I don't trust a
woman there's something negative in
there you guys make it's way too complex
President Obama left very popular but
his policies warrant for eight years
people were frustrated he wasn't tapped
in people were unmotivated all he did
was gradually lose the entire party and
not fun the DNC and build himself up
people liked him they didn't like his
administration they didn't like the way
was executed nothing to do with the fact
that she's a woman if you put Tosi
Gabbard against Nikki hailey it's game
on
it's a someone who's a veteran that
understands people that that has a lot
to offer be something totally different
she did not lose because she was a woman
she didn't get a vote because she was a
woman by the end of it it was two
candidates and they took the person that
they thought would be the most
dramatically different from President
Obama that's a good head to head that
you just brought up by the way that's
gonna be the future can we save this
show do it we take any show you're on we
burn it's fine it's in our lives and a
bylaws Department approved a lot of
shine